Cuáles son las causas para que estos dos
bancos hayan quebrado la razón en común
es el aumento de intereses que ha habido
Bueno no es por el aumento de intereses
que sino sobre todo por la acumulación
de riesgo que se ha generado Durante los
años de la expansión monetaria hemos
visto como estos bancos tomaban una gran
cantidad de bonos del Estado a largo
plazo para utilizar como colchón de
capital y como colchón para sus activos
en un en un entorno en el que se
percibía como el activo de menor riesgo
que es lo que ha ocurrido en el año 2022
los no solamente cayeron los precios de
las acciones en el mercado
norteamericano y el mundial sino también
el de los bonos soberanos Y qué es lo
que pasa estos bancos se encuentran con
por un lado salida de depósitos y por el
otro lado unos activos que son bonos
soberanos que han perdido un 20% de su
valor y por lo tanto pues reciben
inmediatamente un shock en el que
pierden en esa en esa diferencia las
pérdidas latentes en su portafolio de
bonos soberanos y de activos ligados a
hipotecas pues pierde prácticamente toda
su capitalización por lo tanto es muy
importante ahí que haya entrado el fondo
de garantía de depósitos y que la
reserva Federal haya constituido Esa esa
facilidad para que los depósitos no
pierdan su valor y precisamente por esa
intervención de la que usted nos habla
es que escuchamos las palabras del
presidente estadounidense sin embargo
ese no fue el único país en pronunciarse
México Reino Unido y Francia también
Hicieron un llamado a la calma porque es
necesario frenar esos temores y Se
podrían extender las consecuencias de la
quiebra de estos dos bancos a otras
naciones
es importante Llamar a la calma y
recordar que se han tomado decisiones
importantes para frenar el contagio
porque el contagio la pérdida de
confianza de los ciudadanos que por
ejemplo puedan decidir sacar el dinero
de esos bancos a toda velocidad aunque
los bancos estén en una situación
completamente diferente y mucho más
sólida que la de estas dos entidades
norteamericanas claro eso puede generar
una corrida bancaria y un riesgo mucho
mayor Yo creo que es importante Por lo
tanto restablecer la confianza de los
depositantes yo creo que ese es el
factor primero y clave y el segundo Es
que la reserva Federal tiene que dar
alguna facilidad de liquidez que permita
a los bancos que tienen un colchón de
activos en bonos a largo plazo de
Estados Unidos en este caso puedan
intercambiarlos en la reserva Federal
por bonos a corto plazo o bonos más
líquidos y que les nos permitan llevar a
cabo su actividad de manera
normal sin entrar en un problema de
solvencia y de liquidez a la vez por
algo que no tiene nada que ver con la
con la actividad o con de la gestión del
banco no es que
se le haya tenido una mala gestión
verdad sí y justo usted Nos estaba
hablando de una facilidad que debía dar
la reserva Federal de Estados Unidos yo
le quiero preguntar qué Debería ser
sobre los intereses porque Antes había
dicho que podría Elevar Estos tipos de
interés Usted cree que ahora repensar a
sus posturas
yo creo que no debería hacerlo le voy a
decir porque a los que a nuestros
televidentes si la reserva Federal
decide ahora parar las subidas de tipos
de interés el riesgo de que la inflación
siga elevada y durante más tiempo es
mayor y por lo tanto los activos de los
que hablaba antes bonos a largo plazo
bonos ligados a hipotecas las propias
inversiones En activos que
necesariamente estaban sufriendo esa
pérdida de valor cuál es el problema que
se haría mayor esa pérdida es decir lo
que ahora mismo es algo que es
gestionable con una facilidad de crédito
de liquidez sería muy difícil de
controlar si se generase una nueva caída
de los activos financieros mayor a la
del año 2022 o similar al 2008